graciées la question des droits de
l'homme est en débat aux états unis
ainsi cette semaine le patron la cei a
reconnu que ses services avaient eu
recours à la simulation de noyade lors
d'interrogatoires de terroristes
présumés des sommes liées aux attentats
du 11 septembre 2001 alors cette
pratique de la torture at elle été
légitimée par l'administration était
légale le point sur ces questions à
washington avec alan chalvron et aaron
dimon on appelle cela le waterboarding
forme améliorée si l'on peut dire de la
torture de la baignoire déjà largement
utilisé au cours du dernier conflit
mondial
ce mode d'interrogatoire est
régulièrement dénoncée dans les
manifestations pacifistes comme illégale
mais voilà les états unis l'ont bien
utiliser aveu tardif du chef de la cia
waterboarding a été utilisée sur trois
détenus notamment khaled cheikh mohammed
et la cia ne l'a pas utilisé depuis cinq
ans le chef des opérations d'al qaïda
khaled cheikh mohammed
arrêté en 2003 au pakistan est depuis
détenu à guantanamo est donc une des
victimes de cette technique et il faut
bien dire qu'elle a eu un certain succès
valais il a commencé par nous donner les
informations sur les chefs d'al-qaïda et
sur les opérations qu'ils étaient en
train de créer après le scandale d'abou
ghraïb la législation sur la torture a
été durcie en 2005 et 2006 sans
toutefois que le supplice de la
baignoire soit spécifié d'où la question
la fin justifie t elle les moyens
peut-on continuer à pratiquer cette
technique est là les avis divergent
il n'est pas sûr que ce mode
d'interrogatoire seraient considérées
comme légales seront la législation
actuelle statut et les excès liés aux
techniques légales si on l'utilisé dans
des circonstances très particulières
interrogé sur cette page aux divergences
entre chef espion
la maison blanche a tout simplement dit
qu'il ne fallait rien exclure autrement
dit si on a encore besoin de la
baignoire et bien on l'utilisera retour